[Applause]
we don't seem to have Barry
unfortunately won't be able to see your
husband today I'm not about to let
Amunet turn me into a weaponized slave
come on it's a freaking awesome
Barry's completely unharmed
you can rest easy he's in good hands
tell us what you want an eco-friendly
that better not see the flash either
believe in the impossible possible
that's impossible and the impossible
suiting him to party now
I'm taking him to the hospital
- Tuesday 37 central on the CW
everybody is time for a prison break on
the Blash and it looks like they're
gonna be going on break for a couple
weeks after next week's episode for at
least two weeks so I'll explain the
schedule again at the end of this they
also drop the pre loot for a flash war
which is going to be badass so I'll
explain what's going on with that at the
end of the video but the whole deal is
is that batery
is stuck in the Med human wing with the
other bust metas that are in there
there's only four of them that we see in
the trailer but if you haven't seen them
in a while it's black bison hazard
Kilgore and then dwarf star from last
week's episode because they just locked
him up so naturally he'd be right in
there and the whole deal is is that they
don't know that he's the flash they just
know that he's a metahuman like them
because he's locked up in their special
wing so part of the episode like as you
can see he's macgyvering his way out of
that prison cell using special chemicals
instead of trying to use the flash
powers so that he doesn't have to
completely give up his identity because
he's not wearing his costume so the
minute the the Speed Force manifests
around his body they would know
instantly who he is but because hazards
standing there and nothing's on fire
nobody is getting hurt I'm guessing that
they all have met a human power
dampeners on because otherwise she would
just passively give everybody else bad
luck in their escape attempt would fail
immediately it's a little Shawshank
because they probably do escape but also
a little Escape from Alcatraz meaning
that not everybody escapes the legit way
because you see Barry going up against
them in the prison yard with all that
metahuman riot gear remember that's the
riot gear that we saw during the black
bison episode that she turned into a
golem remember they had this badass new
gear they're like alright let's play
with this a little bit boom she turns it
on and it starts going after them
Terminator style frontal impact
deflection panels a dual filter gas mask
so you don't cry on your own supply any
questions
a lot of this storyline is borrowed from
Jeff John's thinker storyline in the
Wally West era what happened is as a
bunch of metahumans got locked up there
ended up being this big prison break now
the circumstances were very different
but the whole idea was is that there was
always metahumans to just bust out it
was a huge Prison Break story but it was
sort of adjacent to what the thinker was
doing so the blacksmith of the comics
was never really working hand in hand
with the thinker they were just doing
two separate things in two separate
cities in Keystone in Central City they
both hated the flash separately but the
thinker had his own plan that he was
doing all by himself the thinker of the
TV show is sort of using all these
things to bring about his goal so it
sounds like he's also using Amunet to
buy all these metahumans but the idea is
is we don't know what technologies he's
using to mind-control them so she
probably has a metahuman that enables
her to take control of them mentally but
a lot of you saw Barry get thrown into
that cell at the end of the last episode
you're like wait a minute didn't he bust
out of the pipeline prison in episode
one because he was so powerful after
coming out of the Speed Force what's up
with that like how come the prison cells
able to hold him they didn't really
explain some of the changes in his head
since he came out till more recently
where they addressed the gibberish that
he was speaking when he came out like
we're gonna need more diapers and like
all the lines of dialogue that he spoke
from previous episodes and stuff that's
probably gonna happen in future episodes
he was like yeah I have no idea what I
was talking about and he barely
remembers what was going on so as far as
he knows the information about the
symbols is either trapped somewhere in
his consciousness just waiting to be
unlocked like there's some memory that
he has that needs to be triggered by
something else maybe by this person
who's writing in the diary who
mysteriously looks like she might be
Barry and irises daughter and also talks
a lot like Barry but I think the basic
idea is is that when he came out of the
Speed Force he was like this fully
actualized Jedi Master flash with just
like crazy power levels that then sort
of receded once his mind started
existing back in our dimension so he
winds up forgetting a lot of that stuff
and that also makes him forget how
powerful he is in the Flash's abilities
are largely tied to his own
understanding of them like he learns
he has new abilities that he didn't know
that he had before but he always had
them it's not like he gets more powerful
or faster with time it just he learns to
use his powers in a more sophisticated
way so if you're wondering when we're
gonna see like the fully actualized
super Jedi Master Flash berry from
episode 1 it's probably gonna have
something to do with defeating the
thinker and the mystery person who
seemingly understands the Speed Force
symbols that she's writing down in that
diary like if she's writing them that
means that she fully understands the
language so getting into flash war if
you guys didn't know what was going on
there's a new event that's happening in
the comics this year called flash war
they just sort of teed it up in the
flash annual this past week it's not
gonna be happening till May but it's
basically meant to be the culmination of
the ginger Wally West storyline since
rebirth so he comes out of the Speed
Force and they're sort of meshing new 52
continuity with pre-crisis continuity
and all these other eras in the comics
that previously they used to just brush
aside so there's all these
contradictions going on there are
characters that don't remember him like
this is the Wally West flash that took
part in the thinker arc where at the end
of that he and Linda Park found out that
they were pregnant with their twins
remember Wally West had twins Barry and
iris also had twins separate from that I
guess twins just run in the flash family
so Barry is trying to get him to figure
out how to be Wally West and not just
the version of the flash that he's been
this whole time so he has this small
identity crisis but he starts to figure
it out by the end of the story just
teeing up that okay I'm gonna figure out
who I am and it makes it sound like
they're gonna be keeping him around
because a lot of people are like wait a
minute are they gonna kill off this
version of Wally West what's going on
but parallel to this in the 25th century
they're investigating wreckage at the
flash Museum so it's sort of the
aftermath of this storyline where the
reverse-flash
eobard thawne takes Iris and Barry to
the future to try and torment them Barry
got the negative Speed Force for a
little while iris West uses a special
anti speedster gun to kill yo Bart
Thawne they go back to present day in
ubar Thawne is still dead that's the end
of it but you don't really see the
aftermath so you're getting that in this
story and you see like all these
artifacts that are east
all over this page here you see flashes
from all kinds of different eras this is
the Walter West flash this is Johnny
quake from the crime syndicate
remember it's the flash Museum so there
are dioramas of almost every adventure
that the flash has ever had so you have
these people investigating they're like
did anybody see which version of the
flash caused these big problems and they
figure out that iris West is the person
who killed
eobard thawne so the time bureau of the
future sends the Renegades back in time
if you guys don't remember the Renegades
they're like a future version of the
Rogues that are actually good characters
so they go back in time to apprehend
iris West then at the end they tease the
beginning of flash war I'll say careful
for spoilers so here we go so they tease
the zoom the hunter zolomon version of
the character has been trapped in the
25th century this whole time and he just
been trying to figure out how to help
the flash family because he's a total
psycho and he does that by challenging
them but because he was most significant
to the Wally West flash like professor
zoom is mostly a Barry Allen villain I
mean he's a villain for all the Flash's
but he was most significant for the
Silver Age Barry Allen character so in
the way that Geoff Johns sort of
upgraded a lot of the villains during
his Wally West run he also upgraded
reverse flash and instead of professor
zoom it was hunter zolomon taking the
mantle of zoom in his powers worked a
little bit different his motivations
were different but he was mostly a Wally
West villain so it totally makes sense
that he would tea up the idea of getting
the Flash's to war with each other to
make them stronger like his whole idea
is that he's making them better by
making them fight each other but it all
sounds like it's gonna be a lot of fun
so it's gonna be dropping in May I'll
totally do videos for when it gets here
but just post all your TV show or Flash
work questions in the comments below
there's a new brand of that flash ring
giveaway - I'll be posting my black
lightning video next so I'll just
announce the giveaway winner when I post
that so that should be up in the next
couple of hours but click here for my
episode 12 video and click here to
rewatch that ant-man the wasp trailer
remember super bowl stuff coming up this
weekend - thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight